[موسيقى]
الارتباط الأجنبي هو آلية أساسية للبقاء
تطورت
منذ ملايين السنين حتى نتمكن من العثور على
الشريك المناسب وإرسال حمضنا النووي إلى
الغد، إنها آلية أساسية لبقاء الإنسان.
هيلين فيشر
عالمة أنثروبولوجيا بيولوجية تدرس الحب الرومانسي
والارتباط وكيف  إنه يؤثر على
الدماغ ليس فقط عندما تقع في الحب ولكن
أيضًا عندما تسقط منه.
لم يكن هناك من يحب على قيد الحياة. نحن جميعًا
نعاني عندما يتم رفضنا عندما قمنا أنا
وزملائي بوضع 17 شخصًا
تم رفضهم للتو في الحب.  وجدت
حوالي ستة أو سبعة أشياء تحدث في
دماغ كل شخص، منطقة دماغية
مثل مشاعر الحب الرومانسي ولكنك
تظل نشطًا، ولا تقع في حب
شخص ما
لمجرد أنه هجرك، بل يمكنك
حتى أن تحبه  هم أكثر يتجدد الدماغ
بمشاعر الارتباط العميق تنشط وتظل
تشعر بالارتباط بالشخص
منطقة الدماغ المرتبطة بالألم
الجسدي تنشط عندما
يتم رفضك أه ثم هناك ثلاث
مناطق في الدماغ مضاءة بالرغبة
والإدمان خاصة
مصنع صغير خاص يسمى النواة
المتكئة وهذا المصنع يصبح
نشطًا مع أي نوع من الإدمان مثل إدمان
القمار، إدمان الطعام، إدمان الجنس، وهي
منطقة في الدماغ
تصبح نشطة أيضًا عندما
يتم رفضك في الحب، أعتقد أن
الحب الرومانسي هو إدمان  يمكن أن يكون
إدمانًا رائعًا تمامًا عندما
تسير الأمور على ما يرام،
وإدمانًا فظيعًا تمامًا عندما تسير الأمور بشكل سيئ،
فنحن نعاني أساسًا لأنه منذ العصور القديمة،
عرّض هذا قدرتك على
إرسال الحمض النووي الخاص بك إلى الغد للخطر،
وهذا هو بقائك على قيد الحياة، فلا عجب أننا نعاني
كثيرًا
ولكن الأمر ليس كذلك  كل الألم والمعاناة
هناك شيء واحد لاحظه فيشر وهو أنه
يساعد في تخفيف مشاعر الحزن
والرفض كلما طالت
فترة الرفض تلك، مع
مرور الوقت، ترى نشاطًا أقل فأقل في
أجور الدماغ المرتبطة بالتعلق، وقد
تمكنا من إثبات ذلك  هذا الوقت لا يشفي